tout autre sujet à présent nous allons
parler sécurité dans le département
vendredi dernier à la mairie de
versailles les forces de sécurité de
l'état les services de police municipale
ont signé une convention de coordination
une signature entre le préfet serge
morvan et le maire françois de mazières
qui permettra de préciser la nature et
les lieux d'intervention des agents
municipaux en déterminant les modalités
de coordination avec la police nationale
et la gendarmerie
cette convention permettra également aux
agents le port d'une arme après avoir
suivi une formation
une décision qui a été prise suite aux
attentats survenus en france durant
l'année 2015 écouter cette annonce
permet effectivement l'armement des
policiers municipaux et mais elle date
de quelques mois déjà et mais par contre
c'est d'abord aussi la volonté de la
municipalité de la commune de signer une
convention avec nous c'est aussi nous
notre souhait pour que les actions de la
police municipale et des forces de
sécurité police et gendarmerie sur
versailles soit encore mieux coordonner
qu'aujourd'hui nous avons souhaité que
notre police municipale soit armé c'est
une décision qui n'est pas facile mais
elle correspond aussi au soulier et des
policiers municipaux
donc nous allons le faire dans des
conditions les meilleures avec un
processus de formation progressif est
évidemment destinée à ceux qui le
souhaitent il faut être volontaire dans
ce type de démarche
et puis on nous aurons ensuite
le bénéfice des armes fournies par deux
miss aux matériaux etc